vous avez évidemment suivi cette réunion
extraordinaire du conseil de sécurité
présidé tout à l'heure par vladimir
poutine
quelles sont les grandes lignes à
retenir de ces échanges autour de
vladimir poutine vladimir poutine qui a
donc réuni autour de lui un certain
nombre d'intervenants pour recueillir
leur avis sur la situation et prendre
une décision dans la foulée
oui sophy en fait vladimir poutine l'a
déclaré la décision doit être prise
avant ce soir donc on attend des
développements très bientôt et vladimir
poutine a souligné que le conseil de
sécurité de russie discuter de la
question de la reconnaissance de
l'indépendance des deux territoires de
la république autoproclamée de deux
nièces quai de lougansk et nous pas de
leur intégration au sein de la russie et
vladimir poutine a également parlé de
l'exécution des accords domise qu'elle a
notamment dit que d'aller les autorités
ukrainiennes actuelles
ne vont pas
respecter ces accords de misc donc et la
russie avec la russie fait face à une
menace sérieuse et très grande en
ukraine a déclaré encore vladimir
poutine dans un contexte de tension
croissante avec les pays occidentaux qui
accusent moscou de préparer une invasion
en ukraine il a également souligné que
l'utilisation de l'ukraine comme
instrument de confrontation avec notre
pays représente une menace sérieuse très
grande pour nous et il a également
souligné que la priorité pour moscou
c'est ne t'ai pas la confrontation mais
la sécurité le président russe faisait
référence aux propositions de sécurité
émises par la russie fin 2021 qui
prévoit notamment
de fixer juridiquement la nonne
expansion notamment de le temps de cette
alliance
atlantique vers l'est comme ça était
avait été convenu il ya trente ans mais
n'a pas été respecté et notamment la
russie plaide à ce que cette alliance
atlantique ne fasse pas d'expansion vers
les pays de l'europe de l'est et les
pays comme le cren la dîmière poutine à
elle a également évoqué lors de sa
conversation avec emmanuel macron cette
nuit il a notamment dit qu'elle a parlé
avec lui jusqu'à 2 heures du matin et
les tractations diplomatiques donc on
poursuit mais elle est le bilan guen
dont l'elysée a tiré de cette
conversation était et est un peu
prématuré au goût riche vous propose
d'écouter
hier nous avons parlé à deux reprises
avec le président français s'était déjà
dans la nuit on peut même dire que
c'était aujourd'hui nous avons parlé
jusqu'à 2 heures du matin il assure
qu'il ya des changements dans la
position américaine mais malheureusement
il n'a pas pu répondre à la question en
quoi consiste-t-il
il a été également confirmé que le chef
de la diplomatie russe sergueï lavrov
doit rencontrer son homologue français
jean yves le drian 1 le 25 février
moscou confirme également la possibilité
d'une rencontre des chefs de diplomatie
américaine française et russe dans un
avenir proche c'est toujours selon les
déclarations de sergueï lavrov mais en
ce qui concerne le sommet au plus haut
niveau dont elle a parlé de manuel macro
et dont la préparation est également
annoncée par l'elysée hier dans son
communiqué la russie attend de savoir à
quel résultat sadran des partenaires
occidentaux après la tenue de ce type de
sommet pour décider de sa participation
écoutez
en ce qui concerne les rencontres
éventuelles avec mes homologues
françaises américain cette possibilité
est étudiée au niveau des ministères des
affaires étrangères
quant aux initiatives du président
macron concernant l'organisation d'un
sommet poutine byden et ensuite d'un
sommet soit de cinq pays avec certains
autres pays invités soit d'un groupe
d'états particulier sur les questions de
sécurité internationale et européenne
effectivement lors des deux entretiens
téléphoniques qui ont lieu ce dimanche
avec le président poutine le président
macron s'est exprimé sur ces questions
mais le président poutine a expliqué
clairement et plus d'une fois que nous
ne sommes pas opposés aux sommets et
réunions mais avant de se réunir surtout
dans un climat aussi tendu il est
important de comprendre à quoi ces
sommets rencontre aboutiront et quel
sera le résultat donc les chefs d'état
russe et français ont convenu que nos
collègues occidentaux qui se prononce en
faveur d'activités de ce genre nous
présenter leur perception des résultats
possibles donc c'est cela qu'on attend à
présent
quant au kremlin on n'exclut pas une
rencontre poutine baden dans un avenir
proche si nécessaire les formalités de
l'organisation seront réglés rapidement
indiqué dmitri peskov porte parole du
président russe mais pour l'instant les
autorités russes ne confirment pas les
informations de l'elysée sur
l'organisation d'un sommet sur la
sécurité en europe le 24 février plutôt
sur la présidence française qui avait
publié un communiqué à l'issue de la
deuxième conversation téléphonique
emmanuel macron avec l'adie mercantine
dimanche soir ainsi que des
consultations avec joe biden et boris
johnson l'elysée ainsi que la maison
blanche précise d'ailleurs que ce sommet
au plus haut niveau ne peut avoir lieu
qu'en l'absence d'une invasion russe de
l'ukraine merci beaucoup verhaeghe
hoffman en direct de moscou nous sommes